hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to our daily homeroom
live stream for those of y'all who this
is maybe the first time that you're
seeing this you're like what is this
link on youtube or facebook uh this is
our way of keeping everyone connected
and when we saw the school closure start
to happen it seems like a lifetime ago
but maybe seven or eight weeks ago
we knew that khan academy had a unique
role to play we saw our usage go up by a
factor of three we started doing parent
webinars teacher webinars and we said in
the time of social distancing it would
also be a way for people to feel
connected if we did something like this
and so this is just form to ask
questions have interesting guests
and make sure that all of you feel
supported
today we have a really exciting guest
i'll introduce her in a second but i do
want to give my a standard announcement
a reminder to everyone that khan academy
we are a not-for-profit organization we
exist because of philanthropic donations
and so if you're in a position to do so
please think about donating to khan
academy i do want to give a special
shout out
over the last several weeks when they
realized that we were already running at
a deficit before the crisis and the
deficit was going to get larger because
of this crisis our server costs our
ability to provide even more supports
they immediately stepped up first and
foremost was bank of america that very
first weekend when we realized that the
school closers were happening uh
followed closely by google.org at t
novartis and fastly have all stepped up
to support this effort so if you as an
individual can help support that is
great and if you are representing a
corporation
that is great as well we still need
more help
so with that i'm super excited to
introduce our guest someone that i've
known for a while who i consider a
friend and i hope she doesn't mind a
mentor someone who i i've gotten a lot
of learning from uh over the last uh you
know almost almost decade that we've
been working together ann fenukin who's
the vice chairman of uh bank of america
and
maybe a good place to start and first of
all you know i hope i'd love to know how
you're doing how you're navigating the
crisis but especially as a leader of an
organization that has 210 000 employees
how are your how are you you how is your
team coping with that and how what are
you all doing to try to support those
210 000 folks
well it's great to be with you so and
thanks for having me uh so it is busy
it's busy for everybody of course but
at the bank we are uh
i'd say 80 percent of the population are
working from home
20 percent are in the office or in the
financial centers because we're
considered a critical service so we have
to be open our doors open trading as
well as being in the financial centers
and it's
like everybody else a lot going on for
everybody people are trying to
keep their kids educated so thank you
uh while also uh
getting to work in some way or another
whether it's at home or in the office
of our 200 you said 210 i think it's 208
000 people uh the first thing we wanted
them to know is that everyone will be
employed for 2020 so that there'll be no
layoffs and that wouldn't be a concern
that they would have
if uh you have child care needs we're
trying to help with that so
we are picking up the cost of uh
trying to help with child care for
everybody
uh whether they're at home or they're uh
in the office
and then um making sure people's medical
needs are
taken care of this is an extraordinary
health crisis uh we've never seen
anything like it i don't think there's
much to fully prepare us but
uh as other guests have said honestly
the uh
the financial crisis uh was maybe a
dress rehearsal 911 was another sort of
dress rehearsal for this and in each of
these cases you're able to learn
something and apply it to the next time
and
you know given
your your experience here well you know
y'all have been stepping up big time and
i mentioned uh you know i i'm not just
having you here because y'all are one of
our big supporters but you are i mean
well for for many many years and then
y'all stepped up even more over this
crisis but this is a part of a broader
strategy that y'all are trying to do
you know you all announced a significant
amount of support for the covet crisis
how are you and that's all things that
are under your uh responsibility how are
you thinking about that where are you
seeing the biggest needs where are you
trying to help where what problems are
are you still trying to figure out
well the first thing is probably what
are we doing for our customers uh like
maybe the first thing is the employees
but i tried to give you a sense of that
for our
uh customers uh those that need it so a
lot of people need help in a time like
this they're either
uh
they've lost their job or they're afraid
they're gonna lose their job or their
partner or wife or husband or whoever
they're living with is uh maybe not
working so
we have offered to our customers and
they can just go on the mobile app and
do this if they need to defer their
mortgage payment their small business
loan their auto loan their credit card
they can do that with a click and um
so we have had more than a million like
a million two
of those uh
deferrals made already and i'm sure that
would continue on for another another
couple of months so that's one very
basic thing
another is to work with our customers on
this uh the cares act the new
legislation so the new legislation has
this program called the paycheck
protection program for small businesses
and
we signed up four hundred thousand
applicants for that ppp program as we
call it and we have put thousands of
people that don't normally do this
against that effort working 24 hours
uh so eight uh three eight hour shifts
to try to help people with uh signing up
for it getting a loan
and um just to give you some stats on
that
about
78 of those that are signing up uh
are asking for something less than a
hundred thousand dollars
more than 75 percent of those have less
than 10 people
so it's really for the small businesses
i mean truly small businesses if you
look at less than 100 people it's about
98 of the population so between
deferring uh payments and setting up
signing up for the uh the payroll
protection program those are two very
significant ways and then what you were
referring to is our philanthropic giving
we give away or we um donate about 250
million dollars a year in philanthropic
giving and we do it at a local level so
we try to uh participate uh through our
market president group in in 90
different markets giving uh to
affordable housing
food insecurity to the homeless uh you
name it but in this case uh we added an
another 100 million dollars and the
reason we did it is because there are
these emergency needs
and actually khan academy was one of the
emergency needs where uh obviously we
have been supportive for several years
and we have a program with you that uh
called better money habits that we are
crazy about and we have millions of
people that have
used it but in a case like this where
you're going to be reaching out to
schools all over the country and helping
teachers and those that are
homeschooling their kids uh get up to
speed
you needed money like today and so uh
same as local food banks and
homeless shelters and some
programs helping people that in the uh
emergency medical field
we felt that we needed to do that very
quickly and a little less paperwork and
a little more uh
uh haste if you will
no and i have to say you know very
transparently i'm not just saying this
because we're on the live stream
together but that very first weekend i
remember we had a meeting with a
schedule with some of your team members
and i was a little late for the meeting
and i was like i'm so sorry i'm late for
the meeting you know we're just seeing a
3x rise in our traffic and you know all
of this stuff is happening and they
immediately said oh well what's going on
and i said our traffic is 3x we're
trying to do all this thing and they're
like hold on we've got to be able to
figure out some way to help you guys out
because this this should be kind of uh
uh and it was literally over that
weekend uh so thank you for that and
y'all were the first and then that
helped i think other corporations to see
the value of supporting this so super
appreciate that i mean there's several
really interesting things you touched on
i am intrigued you know when
you mention the mortgage deferral
and that does feel like the exact right
thing to do when you kind of lead with
your heart because people are not able
to pay their mortgage for reasons
outside of their control right now but
what's the conversation like inside the
bank because on the other side of that
what does it do to the
finances of the bank uh what does it do
to kind of how those mortgages look i
guess you know if you view them as a
financial instrument how do you all
handle that balance
well i think we learned a lot out of the
financial crisis where we had to apply
both humility and tenacity to make our
way through that and as you may recall
there were a lot of foreclosures
there was also a glut of housing on the
market
today it's very different first of all
this is a
health emergency not a financial crisis
although
uh the finances of the industry and of
the country are certainly going to
suffer here
so the thinking around this was let's
see if we can help people defer payments
for a period of time while the country
tries to get back on its feet and with
the hope that through these paycheck
protection programs through our
deferrals through
all that is being done uh legislatively
on a bipartisan basis that all of that
collectively and most importantly the
kinds of things that bill gates was
talking about the other day in terms of
coming up with vaccinations and
continuing
the
physical distancing programs until we
have that
all of that is to prepare for getting
ourselves back uh in shape and i have to
say that um
i talked to our
research analysts yesterday
and what they are uh proposing we're
looking at is we've already had an
almost five percent um
downward turn on our gdp for the first
quarter and that quarter was okay until
march
it's going to be quite extreme in the
second quarter but the third quarter
looks like it's going to stabilize and
then we're going to see a move up in the
fourth quarter if we can apply all that
we're talking about
uh the deferrals the uh the pay the
paycheck program the
the kinds of uh activity that the fed
and treasury are trying to do to keep
liquidity in the system that those
companies that are now sort of on the
sidelines can come back into business
and that may be
well into the summer but you know we're
hopeful and once that happens the
fundamentals of the economy um should
should
in large part come back doesn't mean
that uh restaurants that we all know and
love aren't going to go out of business
it doesn't mean that some small
businesses will have great difficulty
but it does mean on balance that we are
more hopeful so we see in aggregate
probably about uh
sort of the ups and downs i just talked
about maybe a six percent
uh downward trend for 2020 and probably
about the same up for 2021.
that's super useful and i want to
encourage everyone who's listening uh we
have team members who are looking at the
message boards on uh youtube and
facebook so feel free to put the
questions in there get surfaced to
myself and anne and i will ask as many
of these as i can
uh i'll actually i'll start with one of
them and then i have a bunch of
questions for anne i want to go a little
bit into how she became anthony uh
because there's a lot of young people
here i think could get inspiration from
that but from youtube andrea r.316
asks what are some ways to be money-wise
during this pandemic and maybe i'll
extend it you know money-wise generally
well some of the best money-wise
information and advice we have comes
from you sal the work that you do with
us on better money habits and that is
uh it's always good to spend within your
means but now you really have to so uh
there are some benefits right now i mean
interest rates are about zero so
if you don't run up
a deficit on your credit card if you can
try to live within
uh your means uh that really helps
i would put up big purchases right at
the moment you know mortgage uh
applications
are down 40 that's usually a pretty good
bellwether of where we're at as a con as
a country
but it's different this time in that um
there are also not a lot of houses on
the market for sale so it's not like it
was 10 years ago there's actually very
little on the market for sarah on a
relative basis so i guess what i would
say is
uh
try to
live within your means don't make big
purchases if you can help it uh we all
are
uh traveling less so our gas bill should
be down obviously oil prices are down
and um
i think just try to be prudent with the
decisions you make in the short term
yeah and what ann is referring to we've
had a partnership you know we've both
alluded to it over the course of this
live stream uh for i think it's seven or
eight years now uh we're back in
2010-2011 and this was when khan academy
was a very small organization so
i give bank of america a lot of credit
where they said you know we really want
to uh educate folks and i remember those
first conversations with ann and her
team
uh you know we were a little suspicious
of you frankly we thought you know big
bank where the small startup um
and and we said well you know we want to
have editorial freedom they're like of
course you need that editorial freedom
and so we got into that uh partnership
around better money habits and this
financial literacy because i think both
sides of us think that this is a key
thing i mean if we were
masters of the education system we would
make financial literacy part of that
that school system alongside algebra and
american history and everything else
but i have to say and you know this has
been a really and i don't think i've
actually had a chance to tell you this i
mean the partnership has kind of given
me a lot of faith in that a lot of the
stereotypes folks have about oh you know
big companies they're
because from day one y'all have just
said well what what do you think is
right to tell students and you know we
we
we in our stuff that we publish together
we talk about things some of the same
things that you just alluded to like pay
off your credit card debt as soon as
possible uh try to pay off your high
interest rate type of things you know
leverage your 401k uh if there's a match
and all of that type of thing and
this isn't always in the so so to speak
financial interest of financial
institutions but it's because you all
see yourselves as such major actors
for society generally uh that y'all want
this information out there and you know
i i found that very rewarding that at no
point did we feel that we're in some way
um feeling held back and in our openness
and making making sure we're empowering
folks so that's that i think has been
great so for anyone who's curious you
can check out better money habits you
can check out the personal finance
section on khan academy that was all
that's all work that we've done together
uh
because of sponsorship from bank for
america
so there's a uh question from youtube
j.r foster and and maybe i'll i'll
connect this to your your life you know
the question is how can we be leaders
during a crisis like this one and i'm
guessing jr might be younger we have a
lot of high school students who who
watch this thing but maybe you know how
could you be leaders and i'd love to
connect that you know to get to know you
and fanuc a little bit better you know
how did you end up on the trajectory
that you are on how did you end up
becoming
you know one of the the the leaders the
top leaders in in the financial sector
globally
uh it took a long time
so uh
you know what i want to go back to
something that the the previous uh
guest asked and that was about um what
to do right now there is something
people can do that's unusual right now
and that is that you can if you need
emergency funds you can um
uh
use your for uh percentage of your 401 k
savings without penalty so well we
wouldn't normally advise that that is
cash that's available to be used if you
need it um
how did i become me well um so
i i i am not really a banker actually i
understand banking but my background is
uh was in city politics and then in
broadcasting to advertising marketing
and research
and i came to the bank about 25 years
ago
uh actually a predecessor bankers or an
acquired bank of bank of america
and i was brought in because
they needed some help given that how
many mergers and acquisitions were going
on in the financial services industry
and i probably understood the outside
world better than i understood the
inside of a bank
so i did that work for this um
fleet bank which is a regional was a
regional bank for new england and then
later for the northeast
bank of america acquired us in 2004
and um honestly i didn't think i would
stay with the bank they were um
headquartered in charlotte north
carolina i'm from boston
uh i spent my most of my time somewhere
between washington new york and
boston so i had
maybe been to charlotte once or twice
and mostly just to change playing uh you
know it's a good connecting flight
uh
location
so i didn't think it would work out but
it did work out and it worked out
because um
in their acquisition
of our company
uh there were questions that were being
raised in washington by the head of the
financial services committee in the
house that was barney frank and by the
head of the
senate banking committee chris dodd
luckily for us they were both from new
england i understood what their issues
were and i think that we were able to
ameliorate the kinds of
concerns they had about employment
banking practices etc and i got to know
this company better bank of america and
i was very impressed with the work they
were doing and that allowed me to
uh
maybe show them what i could do and
certainly i was impressed with what the
bank was doing and so we went from there
but as far as the past went i think
everything's uh uh
you know kind of a prologue for your
future you take each thing you have you
try to apply it to the next thing i
didn't understand banking particularly
well banking bankers had been my clients
but i hadn't been inside a bank actually
i'd never been inside a large
public company um other than a brief
time for
a company that then
uh dissolved later so
um
you know you you just one thing begets
another you apply what you've learned
from the past and
you stay where you're happy so in each
of these cases i've been happy
the bank was probably not something i
thought that they would either
particularly like me or that i could see
myself in a big corporation but the
kinds of things we just talked about
earlier the ability to give what will
now be 350 million dollars
to
worthy causes and actually help
whether it's food security or helping
with education or affordable housing or
environmental causes that's really
important stuff and it takes big
companies to be able to do that it takes
small operations as well so when you can
combine
that's really important and the and the
trick is not to overwhelm so in our case
with khan academy i'll tell you and i've
told you this before over dinner that
uh the way we came to khan academy is i
was working with my daughter who had a
learning disability and math was
particularly difficult for her so i
discovered you uh
and uh we started to use uh khan academy
for her to relearn some
math skills that she had
was getting rusty on and it was so good
that i thought wow we're supposed to do
financial literacy and some of what
we've got is kind of boring and i
wouldn't watch it myself which is always
a pretty good bellwether for whether
it's good or not would you watch
something yourself
and i've been watching what you did and
i thought could we could we get you to
come in and help us figure out how to
talk to people and the first
uh video you did for us is the anatomy
of a paycheck
and uh
it was very very successful because who
doesn't want to know your first job
let's just say you think you're going to
be making 500 a week and you look at
your check and it's 275. what happened
to my money so
uh the ability to take people through
what each of those deductions are and
what they mean and whether you'll ever
see it again i thought was so terrific
and if and we had millions of views of
that so if i thought it was going to
work that first video told us it was a
home run
no well thanks for that and and you know
i think your journey i want to maybe
double click on a little bit and it'll
maybe make you feel a little bit awkward
because sometimes tough talking about
yourself or your own strengths but
clearly there's something you know
you've kind of said well you know i was
a bit of an outsider i came to a bank 25
years ago and you know good things
happened you know i like it here and i'm
vice chair of the bank uh what do you
think it was about what do you think
what traits did you bring to the table
that actually maybe aren't even as
obvious uh or as intuitive for young
people out there that allowed you to
thrive and and what people saw in you
that um were they always you know when
there was an opportunity for more
leadership they they essentially said
hey we think that that's a job for
anthony
yeah actually i don't think it went that
way i'm usually not people's uh like the
immediate thought because i am a little
bit of an outsider
but i'm a
lifelong learner i am curious
i enjoy other people so i'm perfectly
willing to absorb your knowledge and
then see if i can apply mine to it and
see if we can get to something better so
i think uh that makes a difference and
over time i i don't like crisis and
we've had plenty of them
so in mergers and acquisitions that sort
of feels like a very acute moment and
that probably is for me when i'm at my
back
so maybe that means i'm a little
flaky otherwise but uh
i i like being able to apply uh
lots of thinking
lots of reading i read all the time
uh the experiences that i've had in
others try to aggregate it take
complicated things and simplify them and
then see if we can make them better and
like i said i enjoy uh working on a team
and i
believe in creativity and i believe
creativity doesn't come from one source
i think it comes in all different uh
manners and from all different people
yeah yeah and i i mean well i think one
of the interesting things you said which
i think is very it definitely resonates
is in a time of crisis i think people
are realizing and that's when you get to
see people and they're who they really
are
and i think people probably seen
something in you your ability to to
handle that well uh
i mean related to that this is actually
jr foster is asking a lot of good
questions from youtube what are some
good leadership skills that you've
developed over the years that you know
they they might not teach in business
school so to speak
read
i think that's what uh that's a very
underrated skill read a lot of it and it
turns out a lot of people don't read
and then
read broadly i mean read the news of the
day read literature
uh
try to pursue what you may not be
particularly good at i'm not very good
at science but i think it's interesting
and i and i read about science and
medical issues
so it's the ability to uh have the
humility to
read and learn what you're not
particularly good at and combine it with
what you like
so i think that's
huge uh reading
uh
listening i think listening is uh way
underrated and
as it turns out further up the food
chain you go the
less people seem to listen so if you're
not the one always talking and you're
listening and you've been reading and
you can aggregate a lot of information
you can simplify it those are leadership
skills i don't think anybody teaches but
for me they've been what's gotten me
through
that's that's very powerful
on on the equity side of things from
facebook we have this question from
christine zhu asking
how are you and the team of bank of
america thinking about issues of equity
in regards to access to capital that
have been potentially exacerbated by
this crisis thank you for your time
well
i i think this paycheck uh program is a
pretty good example of it
if 98 of the people that can get this
small business loan
are indiv are small businesses that have
under 100 people
that is um
an important step to making sure you're
preparing the country because that is
what america looks like
small businesses with under 100 people
so i think it's important that on this
program by the way that
uh the money runs out when the need runs
out and it so
and and it we've had two tranches the
first one was for 350 billion that money
ran out in two weeks
this new one that was uh went online
yesterday at 310 billion dollars is
going to run out
and i think that the congress at
congress has to reallocate more money
until everybody has been served and we
can get businesses so the idea is that
you are able to pay people the next two
and a half to three months while you may
not actually be able to run your
businesses so when that point comes when
you can go back to work or reopen your
business
the uh individuals that have been
working for you have been paid along the
way so it's 75
uh paycheck and like 25 percent is
a rent or mortgage or the kinds of
things that overhead that you would have
for that that's one way of thinking of
it the other is to uh always try to be
fair in your fees to be uh
to try to have programs like better
money habits where you're literally
trying to educate people on how to
improve their fico score rent versus buy
what kind of mortgages might be
available to people first for first-time
buyers
etc so
you know we are the largest consumer
bank in the country we're the second
largest bank but the largest in terms of
the largest small business lender for
instance
we have a very big portfolio in the lmi
community meaning low to moderate income
uh communities
and uh i mean that's evaluated by the
government and everyone else so we have
an outstanding
rating from the government on that
and it's it's being good at those
programs i think we were very good at
them for many years i think the
financial crisis was not only a low
point for the country but a low point
for bank of america i think we took that
in i think we
were chastened by it we made many
changes in the bank
uh whether it's from the really prosaic
things like looking at fees and services
to what we would offer in terms of lines
of business
uh
not having uh overdrafts on um
at point of sale so
just just trying to do everything you
can think of like like laying out
everything you do as a company and
saying is this fair
so we still need to make money uh credit
cards are not free there are interest
rates that go with them if you uh write
a bunch of checks and they're over all
you know
all over drafts you will pay for that
but you won't if you're
if you don't have the money to pay for
something at a point of sale we'll just
have you know you you it won't be able
to be bought because you don't want to
take that overdraft charge you don't
want to keep running up bills that you
can't afford to pay
right and i think it's important
those are some of the things that we
yeah no no that's that's that's
incredible and and no and this is i mean
it's amazing how many questions are
coming through and uh whenever we're
having a good conversation the time
seems to go incredibly fast uh if you
have a couple of minutes i mean there's
a lot of questions people are obviously
curious about the economy itself and you
have a very unique vantage point you
know from facebook marta wingard is this
a crazy time to buy a house chris shaw
from youtube should be investing in the
market since the markets are down
maura kenyo olu
bile is this a good time to refinance a
mortgage so that all goes into this
category of you know people are just
you know should you freeze should you
act uh should you just wait for things
to play out what are the scenarios of
how this economy might play out you
talked about a little bit sounds like
you're expecting hopefully some
normalization in the back half of this
year
yeah fourth quarter is probably the
beginning of the normalization so you
know first of all it's very hard to
because it's a health crisis it's very
hard to predict
when
when the states will open when the
cities will open and therefore when the
businesses will open so we're kind of
following along but presuming that we're
looking at
uh at least some of
of business opening and i'm talking
about small businesses
opening in the summer and perhaps
schools opening in september
uh
we do see normalization of some sort in
the fourth quarter and then as i said in
2021 we see
uh things improving so overall down in
2020 uh at about six percent and about
the same up in 2021. so is it a good
time to buy a house well it's a good
time to buy a house if you already had
you have a house in mind you uh have the
down payment you are still employed uh
you think you will be employed so
if all those things are in place it's a
good time to buy a house it's not a good
time to buy a house if you didn't have
all that in place and you just think wow
maybe it would be a good time to buy a
house because housing prices the the
theory would be that housing prices will
go down they might go down a little bit
but i said earlier something that's
unusual which is there's not a big glut
of available houses on the market and
that's when they really go down so uh
might there be a reduction in housing
prices yes because someone may want to
sell their house because they already
wanted to sell their house
uh but i don't think it will be
pervasive
another question was about the market
buy or sell now well you wouldn't sell
in a down market if you can help but
that's for sure
and um i listened to melody yesterday on
buying when the market is down i don't
give investment advice so i don't think
i should start now
other than to say
i still say live within your means uh i
don't do too much myself in the middle
of a crisis in terms of buying or
selling
and i guess i wouldn't recommend it
yeah and i i'll just triply underline
your live within the means i grew up in
a household you know we used to we used
to reuse paper towels and i actually
only later learned that that wasn't
normal normal behavior we used to always
dry out our paper towels after using it
uh
because we didn't you know my mom made
maybe sixteen thousand dollars a year as
a cashier but that lesson i think if you
have that kind of financial resilience
um it yeah it pays a lot of dividends uh
well beyond timing the market or getting
in on some amazing investment
opportunity
that's great if that happens but um it's
really about
what you yeah
i'll tell you something i am thinking
about which is
uh we have uh we have been working very
hard on uh sustainable
the sustainable development goals
for the last several years and i don't
want uh other companies or our company
and we won't lose sight of the
importance of that so we're the largest
writer of underwriter of green bonds
we're a big issuer of green bonds and
green bonds are like municipal bonds
they're kind of boring
they pay a low interest rate but they
have very low
volatility and the idea behind a green
bond versus a municipal bond is um
that at the end of the the duration of
the bond you have to demonstrate
that it did some environmental goods so
just to use a truly prosaic uh example
is the city of los angeles a bond was
issued for uh them to change over their
uh lighting to led lighting and uh this
is a few years ago now that's okay
that's a good thing to do but in in
doing it they lowered their energy bill
and they
were able to pay the bond off kind of
easily because actually in the longer
term their energy bills their
electricity bills are lower it's better
for the environment and that kind of
innovative thinking we don't want to
lose sight of that in a time like that
and that sometimes happens but i don't
think it will this time uh it just
is uh
it's kind of in the dna i think of
americans to start thinking about this
so we're thinking about it and not
losing sight of how to help on
affordable housing or how to help on the
environment or how to help on education
because these things will be here six
months from now two years from now and
there will be a vaccine at some point
people will be vaccinated there will be
uh remedies for this and these larger
big issues uh don't go away and unless
we continue to invest in them uh they
only were worse than
yeah and maybe related to that just to
finish off on a high note obviously this
is a
a strange time for the whole planet
right now there's a lot of bad news out
there on the health care front on the
economic front
you know dream a little bit could there
potentially be some silver linings could
there be some things that would come out
of this crisis
maybe a little bit better than when we
went in um any ideas on your side
yeah i have a lot of thoughts around
that first of all i think people are
uh
you know your
work many people are working from home
so uh the ability to sort of engage with
your family in a way that you haven't
for a long time is really important and
also an appreciation for those people
that are not working at home that are on
the front lines in a critical job i mean
the people that we have in the banking
centers
whether we're making sure they have
protection and gloves and masts and
bringing in their lunch to them and that
sort of thing you just start to
appreciate those people that are on the
front line and i think about the medical
community and all they're doing i i
think sometimes we take these things for
granted doctors nurses emts uh we don't
take them for granted anymore
in the same way that you didn't take uh
fire fighters and uh
the police after 9 11. you you looked at
people differently i think this is an
opportunity to look at things
differently obviously because we are
driving less
uh the use of um
cars on the road has been reduced so
there's been a little bit of uh if even
if it's just incremental uh improvement
in uh greenhouse gas emissions
so those are a couple of good things
that i think are worth noting
yeah no i think that's a great one and
that first one is alluding to maybe we
all feel a little bit more gratitude for
those around us and the gratitude for
what we what we've had and maybe what we
still have even though things are tough
and and very tough for a lot of folks
well and thank you so much this was a
you know really fun conversation i hope
you're willing to do this again there's
so many questions here that i would it
would be like to be nice to draw down
that backlog at some point but but thank
you so much and thank you for being such
an incredible supporter for khan academy
through the years around financial
literacy and especially uh through this
crisis
well sal thank you and thank you for all
you do you know you've been a great
partner for us for the last several
years
as i mentioned earlier your videos have
actually changed how we think about
financial literacy and actually what we
think about what people want to know so
we look forward to continuation with you
as a partner and uh all that you're
doing and thank you for everybody that
tuned in today
thanks ann
so uh i just want to say
thank you everyone for for joining uh
that was another super fun conversation
with someone that i've as i mentioned
view as a mentor and really look up to
and and have learned a lot from and
hopefully i think y'all have gotten a
lot from her as well
i just you know stay safe stay healthy i
will see everyone tomorrow and remember
we are not for profit if you're in a
position to do so uh please think about
making a donation to khan academy so
that we can support many tens of
millions or actually hundreds of
millions of learners around the world
thank you so much
you